each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so I'm very pleased to be here is
2012 PhD Microsoft Research Cambridge
summer school and I'll try to tell a
little bit about what we do in the
organization where I belong to
microservices connections a little bit
of my background in on his right as he
was said in my introduction yes today is
a great day for my former organization
the European Center for particle physics
so after more than 30 years work and
after 40 years of the Higgs theory first
announced by Professor Higgs in
Edinburgh while we have all the reason
to believe that the eggs particles are
there we're more or less we're expected
to be at under 25 GV of mass of energy
mass and yeah I mean so today I mean
early in the morning it was a major
announcement at CERN and well I mean
he's a big accomplishment and you know I
feel still very very excited so and that
is not just there is only the beginning
I mean you know now there are many many
years of physic research to be a to be
done based on that so yeah so they're
basically cover what I wanted to say for
the people who don't know me so while i
was at served for many years I was in
charge of developing an international
computing infrastructure because you
know CERN is an international
organization and both the the data are
produced internationally and so the
analogy of the data so CERN is very much
a good fit for you know what we're going
to discuss later on in this hour about
you know the importance of the relevance
of cloud computing for for for science
so you know so while a while at CERN I
was developing of those infrastructure
which eventually
was also used by many other scientists
in Europe and you know my major
accomplishment before I joined Microsoft
in 2005 was the eg which was basically
the computing infrastructure that has
been used you know for the four digs
discovery so I you know I feel a little
bit part of the enterprise deal and that
is really very fulfilling and you know
my recent accomplishment in Microsoft
was you know to move from the
distributed computing model available at
that time in the early two thousand to
cloud computing which was have been
doing Venus en going to to speak about
it now I was asked to also say few words
about organization to which you know
myself and scarlet and a number of other
people in kenji belong so we are part of
microservices connection which is an
organization at quarter in redmond part
of microsoft search and in a way is dia
is the outside phase of microsoft search
so microsoft search essentially is
involved in intramural you know internal
research and we used to be called a
standard search to make lea that there
is a power we are a part of microsoft
search really dealing and generating
promoting collaboration with the
external external university attracting
a PhD student student in general
internship coming here I mean you are
part of the program so the intellectual
capital development the support that is
part of this program so you see our
mandate our mission is in a world with a
worldwide academic research community to
speed research improve education and
foster innovation as a result about that
so we do that you know we do
collaboration to somehow enable and
pursuant if you break through
inspire emerging computer scientists
that basically what we're doing here
with school like this one and auxiliary
sent evaporation we computed just by
making access to computing tools easier
for you know the average scientists as
opposite to the scientists that already
know how to do computing for their
research so our Microsoft Research is a
small part of Microsoft we are less than
1,000 people in almost 100,000 people
organization or enterprise and
essentially we operate out of what they
used to be six microservices lab now
they're seven because we recently open
in new york and that doesn't appear yet
in the map I'd you know basically you
see red month which was of course the
first lab to start you know 20 years ago
exactly 20 years ago then we have
silicon valley than where Boston you
know next door to MIT now we have you
know close by web New York so for
research labs in United States and then
at the first research lab outside of the
state is this one that was started about
12 years ago you know 15 years ago
actually sometimes goes from 15 years
ago zuzia here in Cambridge and then
bangalore and then Beijing so altogether
is less than 1,000 researcher little bit
less so one percent of the total
organization but you know we also have a
pretty well-established tradition or
collaborating with the university
research lab etc because clearly we
can't do everything inside inside this
relatively small organization so we have
collaborative incident centers it
sometime I'm responsible for the tvt in
in Europe in greater Europe including of
course the Russian Federation and an
Israeli another place so you know so we
have a balanced chances are with the
kind of you know yellow so we you know I
will see later we have we have a few in
in Europe Middle East
Africa and that I think is is a
particularly interesting experience that
I want to share with you so I can take
this an example that is there was the
one dot appearing the northwest part of
European stay so in Barcelona in
collaboration with the University Ponte
near Barcelona and please understand
that when we start to join Institute the
funding for the Joint Institute comes
from Microsoft Research connection
Microsoft Research at large but also by
the local funding agency we don't go in
a while in a research lab like this one
in Cambridge is entirely funded by
Microsoft Research so entirely own
started operated by US a journey steeda
as the name suggests is a joint effort
so we contribute to the budget we
contribute to their four-week on to the
research but the jointly managed and
funded entity so that is essentially are
funded by University Polytechnic of
Catalunya the Barcelona supercomputer
center belong to the to you PC to
University of Montana catalunya and and
a microsoft search so there we do it
number thing transactional memory which
is something that we're kind of wrapping
up or suturing structural member has
been successfully used by their company
like Intel IBM and so forth we are not
sure that that part of development still
that critical for microsoft search so
that is san siro wrapping up but you
know Tim Harris who was in the lab until
a few weeks ago and now moved to another
position outside Microsoft has been our
primary counter in other countries of
the Joint Institute they have an encore
so they're collaborator in Microsoft
Research which are really prime
investigator in India tivity language
runtime system so we do we develop
architecture support to accelerate a
number of activity negate there was a
kind of natural spinner for the TM staff
and then newer activity we start last
year were low power vector
so which is potentially very very
important because as you know the living
now to build a larger computing
infrastructure larger computing machines
and systems is the power so really being
able to develop architecture that are
particularly low in power consumption is
very clear from Microsoft like for
everybody else we have another instant
party who are near to parties in cycling
in collaboration area you probably know
the inner as one of the largest and most
successful computer science research
organization public funded in in Europe
and and there we do essentially a
fundamental computer science software
verification formal methods and and so
for and again you decide of those
Institute that is typical n t5 personal
computer students so that is a little
larger than Barcelona Barcelona's maybe
20 and then we have another one in
collaboration with University of Toronto
and that is more focus on applied
computer science to computational system
biology so there we really try to use
the best of our technology and the best
of of University of trained to expertise
to develop tools for the pharmaceutical
industry from the nutritional industry
we have recently sign agreement with
Novartis to help them to develop new
drugs and we initially to develop them
to you know to develop new kind you know
you probably her personalized medicine
so basically the idea that you know you
will be able to design drugs for a
specific passion as opposite to generic
drugs for everybody the idea that we
evaluate Nestle do the same for food so
you know you can develop food which is
particularly good for the genetic
profile of a one customer so that is
really of course you know far in the
future but as you can imagine
tremendously important you know for for
industry models you know for their for
the good of the people
and then you know we have you know just
few months ago we started similar a
smaller a pilot in Turkey which is a
spin-off of the Barcelona Institute and
there we try to apply formal method
verification to transactional memory
which is a kind of a gap I mean there is
no much about that and transactional
memory are normally used in very very
large-scale parallel processing system
so really having tools that are plow
apply a support software verification in
such a large multi-threaded code is
definitely very important for us and
that is something that we start the last
October in Russia we have been running
for the last several years a number of
activities with what the Russians am GU
I mean MSU in English the Moscow State
University and in particular over the
last couple of years concentrating on
computer vision our P I is here is push
meet and and kasten ruther here in
Cambridge and then Moscow State
University aunt Olga and the number of
other people involved so that is
interesting because it's not yet reach
the dimension of a journey Institute you
might become a John Institute of course
to become a genista to moscow state
university autorities that we need to
chip in resources so far has been
essentially our resources and of course
in-kind contribution from Moscow State
University in in terms you know paying
salaries for the senior investigator as
part of this activity we run a school
similar to this one last year so
probably you you will see some familiar
faces there and like this school has
become extremely popular so we had more
than 420 registration from more than 70
cities from the Russian Federation and
eventually we selected 80s to
the numbers are similar to here and you
know we went through one week of
intensive lectures and exercises on
computer vision as the spin-off okay let
me stay months ago there as a spin-off
of that I didn't put a slide on on this
but it will be covering tomorrow we
decide to run a student competition
using our key net SDK and we had a
number of projects developed and
submitted and then we have a mix
microsoft and sternal advisors selection
committee push meet was one of the
members and we eventually selected five
winners and the five winners got
scholarship to be here so can maybe I
ask somebody okay one two three four
five yeah everybody's there so they they
were the lucky one actually the people
who work harder than some of the others
and I think you're going to present what
you have done I think tomorrow sometime
on thursday not tomorrow yet amorous but
it is today wednesday ok so today's way
so it must be in cambridge ok so
tomorrow yeah so it's tomorrow i think
around four ish or something like that
you know ok anyway you will be able to
know more about Bob Ojeda and you know
you can recognize maybe Andrew Blake the
guy that you know didn't didn't get a
t-shirt because it didn't work hard
enough in the school so you know where
we didn't give me a t-shirt so is they
actually the managing director here in
the lab and one of our top senior
scientists and you know well famous
computer vision specialist PhD
scholarship I don't need to tell you
much about it you know so we're on that
on behalf of the organization and you
know we have other some school like this
one and I think you know the the most
important thing I think is that getting
people familiar with the whole go-kart
did you did you get the go-kart outing
okay
fine yes everybody was happy no one good
heart no okay good good yeah yeah
sometime we had little bit of casualties
but you know it happens okay so so
that's basically all I wanted to say
about what we do in in Americanization
if that were a question you know you now
know after Simon's Python Jones
presentation know when to ask arrest and
when not to ask the question etc and I
don't Phylly don't agree with anything
he said I mean I Iran presentation a
complete different where don't prepare
presentation or molly is much better you
know you get more spontaneous so you
know you ask question as I go if you
don't ask question I don't care we can
discuss later on you know is a is is it
really a chart is not a formal
presentation so anyway that's all what I
have to say on what we do we can discuss
later if you are more interested if you
want to understand how to submit propose
that to get so far from us how to start
an institute or anything guy you like to
discuss I mean you know I like to
discuss everything I think you know
during the coffee break I was discussing
the difference between castellum and
cattle on the origin of the languages
it's very exciting subject I like very
much languages so you know whatever you
want now second thing data and somehow
the transformation is science that they
technology evolution over the last
specifically about you know ten years
over the last ten years when really know
the moral laws start to really impact on
us at all possible level not just in
community but you know in you know
detent managing data storage data
archive the technology there now allow
to make in a sense so so cheap I don't
know probably you have had something
about gadgety and other stuff but now
you know you can find you can you know
by with you know a few dollars sensor
that are capable to generate a lot of
data so you know really you know this
kind of explosion of data data balance
you know you probably heard all those
those numbers so now you know we leave
and we're moving in
in an era where you know petabytes is
common I mean you know you want to store
you know data as a backup you know you
used to buy you know you know a few
hundred gigs now you know you bye-bye
terabytes unitary know a terabyte sees
as a form factor like that and as you
know i mean you know it costs nothing so
petabytes now is nothing special and by
2020 which is almost there according to
me see more than one-third of all
digital formation that is created you
know annually with either leave or pass
through to the cloud so so you know not
only we are observing this giganti
amount of data production but the data
are going to be available to everybody
so the data are going to be not any
longer store in one location but in a
store in a virtual storage which
everybody can access and that is
happening now now when I say the data
you know you know you you know I think
it's very appropriate to start from the
LSC the Large Hadron Collider so that is
is is a piece of the Atlas detector that
has been contributing and detecting the
signals deafness the EEGs that is is the
simulation is a computer simulation or
one heat and then of course all those
data core to our calves and archives of
course are either sitting in
conventional computer centers data
center and just data center there
virtualized and then become the cloud as
we discussed later eventually you know
the the science you do on the data be
comfy soul eater which you access and
again you access in a digital form and
is all available on their on their on
the cloud eventually and instruments i
said you know those are sophisticated
instrument but now instrument become
commodity you put this drama everywhere
and you generate giganti amount of data
so so that is you see digital form a
sugar annually we grew by facto 44
between 2000 and enters at 20 I mean so
is gigantic and that is happening we
like it or not so what is going to
impede on science I mean
is not only you know the data that you
know did the physic data that we produce
with the sperm etc but you know also the
output the output science it goes to to
journal goes to papers and those are
also you know a pedir in electronic form
so if you are a scientist you are
confronted with the scientific data that
you collect you want to access but also
to the the kind of thing you used to do
an elaborate used to go to the library
to read the latest paper today the
latest proceeding now you have
everything online so you have submerged
by data in a positive direction so what
is the impact well I mean you might have
heard of the emergent well it's not an
emergency long you know the force
research paradigm which you know
scientists like Jim Gray 10 years ago
were anticipating is there so we move
from experimental science which is the
natural science that's been done from
the you know from ever since you know
since humankind start to observe nature
to theoretical science that you know
basically you know started with that
well actually we Galileo Galilei and
eventually perform you know improved by
Newton's and everybody so basically try
to reason on their servation build
models and and eventually when the
computer came that could be accelerated
because then you could really use
computer to simulate phenomena that then
you could then observe and by comparing
in a simulation with the observation you
could infer in approve or disapprove the
theory and now we are basically moving
from you know theoretical so you know
decide on the theory similar to the
computer and that go for some
reservation to really look at the data
and and the data is gigantic and the
data are I think of young nunez slides
yeah if you want to to understand better
about that you know this book is
available on the on the websphere can
take it and what i wanted to do yeah so
all those data is not just making
science more interesting
more valid but he's also changing the
approach i mean the the best example I
like to leave the approach when I was at
the University I was very much involved
in a machine translation you know
automatic machine translation and we're
using a formal approach where we are
trying to take a language define the
signals defined the grammar you know
define the vocabulary and basically
writing at that time i was using
prologue so I was using logic
programming and we're basically defined
rules by which you know you could take a
phrase they compose the phrase analyze
the phrase and translating another
language that was a very complex process
which I think work more or less but we
never managed to make a system of
automatic translation the people could
use I mean were plenty of good example
proof of evidence but you know nobody
could really use it you know I they did
the translation mean you know there were
a lot of jokes and particularly since I
was mentioned Russian before one of
those system you know the joke I mean
maybe is true but you know for me it's
more a joke people were trying to build
a system to translate from English to
Russian and you know the phrase that was
used it was a phrase of the gospel for
those of you are familiar with with the
Bible watch live with the gospel there
is you know when Jesus Christ is is in
the desert is tempted by the devil and
the devil you know basically say you
know tibidabo knew he promised all the
thing and so eventually this a phrase
they say the the spirit is strong but
the flesh is weak and and the automatic
translation in Russian translated in the
spirit is strong translated the vodka
was good but the meat was not very well
cooked okay so well you know you can
guess but you know it was not really
useful so now we change completely the
approach now we have a lot of data so we
completely forgotten the formal
approachable and statistic machine
learning
statistic okay so basically the machine
learning approach is to use example so
you build sis that you don't even need
to know russian or english you just need
to feed the system with a large amount
of example since the english this is the
Russians is the Russians in English and
the more you are the more the system
will learn and also you know system to
tend to be interactive so if you are an
expert if you know both languages you
can actually help the system by
correcting the an improving in
translation so now you have automatic
translation which is not perfect but i'm
sure you know everybody of you is
famille on you know you take being you
take Google you take whatever system you
go there and you get translation from
any language to any other language it's
not perfect but is enough to understand
what that paper is talking about often I
do for abstract I look at the absurd
maybe the answer is in a language I'm
not familiar with I go for a translation
and you know is enough for me to see if
I'm real interested in that paper in
that case I can ask for a for a better
translation or not so that has been done
because now we can under petabyte of
data so that for me is a typical example
what we what we mean when we say that we
move to the four generation paradigm of
science so I you know to to summarize
that as I meant you have the literal
where the revived recombine data in the
raw data so basically dis periment input
data there you work on the data and you
eventually produce litter so all these
basically used to be done a partial in
the computer parts in the library there
was a lot of you know human interaction
need to go to conference you need to go
to meeting now everything is up there on
the on the network so the cloud so all
the cloud fit into that so first of all
I assume everybody is familiar with a
cloud but you know just in case you know
just to make sure they will speak about
the same thing because you know
parenthesis we are still
in early days for the cloud I mean the
cloud is real but it still early days so
when there's a new technology in there
are early days the results a lot of hype
you know those of you remember you know
the artificial intelligent and all those
other things there was a lot of high
which eventually made a lot of damages
through today to the scientific domain
but anyway so the cloud we're still at
that point in time where you know if you
talk about cloud is easier to get
funding so many things which had nothing
to do with the cloud they cannot become
cloud I you know I was really very
active promoting grid computing 10 years
ago in the early two thousand and I
remember computing project to me they
basically dad you know to computers and
you know piece of wire oh that is agreed
I said well that is not agree that to
computer connected by a wire it's not a
great but you know if you call it a grid
eat 10 years ago you could get money now
if you could agree now you don't get any
money but if you had the same thing to
computer this two piece of string oh
this is a cloud a cloud okay then UK
here's the check okay so unfortunately
that is the way it goes I'd eventually
things settle down and you know there
was a little a lot of good work done we
agree computing and I stay and it's a
good foundation for cloud computing we
download the work that many people
pretty much have they don't agree we
will not be able to do cloud computing
today but you know just to say so so
Clark computing as a model is nothing
new still another incarnation of
distributed computing like greed or
Vittra cluster or meta computing or
whatever we add in the past so basically
that as the idea that you know every
spiritual eyes so data storage
crystallized computers or separate
relies everything's will try including
nectar access every sis virtualized so
basically you build on demand your own
compute infrastructure and you pay as
you go I mean you pay for what you use
and for as long you use it so the very
flexible very cost effective model and
because it so visualized in principle is
unlimited so for as long as the overall
capacity can support your
virtual infrastructure on the physical
resources you can go so you can ask no
you can have you can start to develop
your prototype on 100 course and then
you can ask 1,000,000 course of course
you will be billed accordingly but if
you can afford Amazon Microsoft you know
what have you are they can deliver to
you 1,000,000 core in the space of two
hours so imaging building and one medium
core infrastructure yourself you would
take you months so is it so the card
infrastructure it is a framework where
you can manage scalable reliable
on-demand access to the application
because of course you can also upload
your application on the cloud so what is
important to understand is this
virtualization and the other thing is
and that's where I mean there is a lot
of rebranding and confusion so you know
an all grid which is and may be built by
peer-to-peer computing model with
thousand of little cluster etc that for
me is not the cloud the cloud really
relies on a relatively small number of
very large huge data and computing
centers because there is where you get
the economy of scale I mean that is a
very old slide you know at least five
years old but you can see that the level
you know if you take the basic component
of any computing system network to
access and you know to communicate among
computing nodes and data servers the
storage the management if you if you see
the typical cost in a in a standalone
conventional computer center in your
department in your University and how
that drops when you move to those used
at the center you know that is the
economy of scale so that's the
continents k that allow you know any
compute computational scientists to have
access to this kind of infinite
computing infrastructure so and that of
course you know is is going through a
tremendous
technical technological development so
so only years ago you know a few years
ago we started with conventional
computer center so the integration was
really the level of rock then we move to
containers technology and now we have a
fully modular integrated containers
which do not need any longer even a
building so you can just have your
containers in the field and an average
you know and have a tremendous cost
effective scalable interaction so if we
take Microsoft clouds you know you see
that is not a gigantic number data
center you know in Europe we have a
dublin and amsterdam then I think now
they are a bit more than these two days
where there were two region and us i
think now we're maybe four and then
wherever if you're there so you know is
a relatively small number or huge data
center with a gigantic natural
cognitively network connectivity in any
disability system is the bottleneck if
you don't have natural conductivity you
do not have a deceiver computer system
and that you can see I mean you know
every time you try to play with any kind
of cloud from your phone etc you see
that at the end of the day was really
slow you down is the network so the
major motivation are obvious 10 years
ago yes ah yeah is that recorded oh ok
so I cannot be sure when I'm in Europe
and I have some data on my cloud that it
stays in the cloud and Europe so it
could be transferred to America or to
Asia is that correct well it depends
there is a tremendous concern because
you know the cloud may be different from
the grid as being a originator for
business application so you know in a
during great time everybody was relaxed
you know we were not concerned with much
with security privacy etc proud is
different because cloud primary target
is a commercial applications business
application now while I'm going what I'm
discussing now how useful is for science
but clearly the concern of privacy data
locality security are essential in the
cloud so and again so my answer is not
specifically for Microsoft cloud
offering I think any cloud commercial
providers offer the customer service
level agreement and as part of the
service level agreement you can define
for instance that your data are not
going to be transferred outside the
national boundary or if you're in Europe
European boundary so you can restrict
your data and say well I I see it in
France or Germany and I'm trusting this
data to say Microsoft cloud as you but I
don't want this data to go to United
States so the data will only go to
answer EE or you can say i want my data
to be enough so that i don't want the
data to go to Dublin so that you can
actually specify when when you submit
your job when you create your virtual
infrastructure and I think any vendor
does that because the there are many
things that are different from a legal
point of view united states in Asia in
Europe so clearly that is a very very
important concern and for instance you
know you know you can you you don't want
maybe your data to even leave your
national country because maybe if you
generate data which have to do with
maybe financial or medical maybe by law
you cannot move medical records outside
even a boundary you know a very small
man during maybe even a region so there
you need to restrict ya know that is is
well understood now is there a perfect
solution well who knows I mean as soon
as you move the data on any network you
are exposed so you know it's always a
trade-off you know probably the
perfect system is possible but too
expensive to a 4 so it's really a
trade-off so if you want my advice i'm
not talking about Microsoft I'm a great
believer of the future of hybrid grid so
we're basically you buy a container you
put the container in your company in
your research center is there you can
put actually physical security in there
you keep the data which are creepy a
confidential and then everything else
which is not that critical you push it
to the club because it's a much cheaper
so I am a great believer that that's
probably for the next few years the best
solution now not everybody support I be
greed I mean clearly Microsoft is
looking into that IBM everybody else but
I'm a great believer that that's
probably the best the best approach and
then of course you know when all the you
know all the countries will that agree
on an international protect data
protection out and everything you know
whenever she would be perfect you know
10 years 20 years from now fine but for
the time you think you know kind of the
ivory greader probably the answer so
anyway very valid question thank you so
yeah the motivation i think you know in
a way we already discuss you know 10
years ago when we were basically pushing
grids you know nobody discuss about
environment nobody were discussing about
energy i was not long ago I mean a few
months ago visiting a petaflop computer
sent are not going to say where I was
and that was fantastic and I say yeah
but we are here in the middle of the big
city so how about the power means is you
know it was you know was like you know a
football field full of with we're acts
of up computing I'm a chef you know what
when I were all together still left okay
so um so said you know that's fantastic
but I mean how about the power and this
the the you know the young the designer
of the center the director said well I
don't care I don't see the power I mean
University pay for the power say oh okay
fine now now I mean that is yeah well I
mean it was a very rich inner easy is is
a very rich university I mentioned the
name of the university heavily
talk so yes said you know interesting
crees but that is changing I mean most
of university around the world are using
the full cost model so if you develop a
computer facility you are going to see
all the cost expose the people that
meant power and energy the power so now
power is a big issue I mentioned before
we work on low power system but again
the cloud because of those huge data
centers you can have a tremendous
reduction on the environmental impact
because you know you can imagine em
users data centers up in the north you
know there are data centers being built
in Europe in using an abandoned or
dismiss you know paper mill factory in
north of feel now there's very cold so
you know cooling is not a big issue and
then there is a major ed electric power
a big damn so you get energy which is
renewable cheap and no cooling probably
just put the containers out in the in
the field and there is no cooling an
essay now the latest generation of
containers they really are capable to to
operate in a normal no air conditioned
environment you know that again thanks
to the development in technology now you
can operate processor access the degree
Celsius you know you remember the days
in which you are entering you know a
computer room and it was you know
freezing cold 20 20 degrees you know 25
already know all our Lars going now we
know we can operate processor we can
operate electronics sustancia at the
same level of reliability at 60 65
degrees so if you allow that then you
can actually use in a cold climate you
know just the you know natural time
pressure no cooling so you can imagine
that if you do that and because you know
the nectar in the meantime our becomes
so powerful you put all your data you
put all our computing in Iceland you
know up at the North and you have a much
lower impact because you need much you
need energy to cool the system
and you know and you can use renewable
energy also because of the
virtualization you can provision i
mention beaver said one medium core well
i mean that can be done in in at most
weeks software few hours you know if you
want to spend you know you just bring
form your containers you know two days
time you want to just build the large
view to infrastructure you can do in a
few hours and then if there is a
disaster you know of course they are
concern if you put your date on the
cloud you don't know somebody could spy
on those some frame authority can allow
you know can can impose to disclose the
data on the other hand if you put the
date on the cloud you don't put any
restriction where they did i go you
might have a copy in your state's a copy
nation copy in europe so in case of a
major disaster you know you have at
least one place where they did are still
available which again is a tremendous
advantage and again you don't incur the
cost of having all those backups and
other stuff so anyway so that i think is
what i wanted to say about the clouds to
make sure that we all agree what the
cloud is and why the cloud is a little
bit change in the game in in distributed
computing so why that yes a little bit
confused about the legal things there so
if i put data on crowd i guess i'm
responsible for the fact that the
content of this data is legal but should
it be legal according to country I live
in or according to country to data
center is yeah yeah is that is the
essence of the problem I mean so in
Europe European Union has just recently
issued a data privacy act which another
application then there is if your
specific interesting too that there is
the activity of an European Union
project I've been involved called
cloudscape so if you look for cloudscape
there's been a lot of discussion about
that and essentially yeah the they say
the common legend
relation at least in Europe say the
people who generate the data responsible
for any legal issue about the data
origin so if you if you if you steal
date and you put it on a cloud while you
are responsible now if the provider of
cloud services fail or maintaining the
data say lose the data now at that point
becomes interesting because save you
have acquired data from company X
operating in France but the data store
in Germany so who do you sue I mean the
people has delivered a service to you or
the people or actually lost the data in
Germany so again the current legislation
Europe say that the people they sign a
contract with you is entirely
responsible towards you and it's part of
what is called SLA so service level
agreement so you you produce data same
France you are responsible to be no fool
according to France low so according to
French low for instance you cannot store
pornography if you stop pornography and
your got caught you are response you go
to j not company X that is starting the
data now companies put the data in
Dublin and that will lose the data
according to european law is the french
company resolve the service to you
they're responsible if then they move
the data to dublin is their business now
is this an international agree
legislation not yet and again on top of
that you have more complicated thing
because you know us low is pretty
straightforward not very different but
there is the patriot act so the patrick
say oh the security of the country is at
stake so the low do not apply in longer
I want this data oh but this data belong
actually to a company that is in
Singapore we don't care you know us you
know security is at stake I want the
data so according to yes Patrick they
can do that in the States but of course
if your data in w they cannot do that so
it's still a work in progress but those
are all valid concern so that's why
again I go back to my previous answer if
the data are critical to you by
container if you
Ford store locally keep it there and
move today to the virtual to the virtual
computer infrastructure also think that
you can protect in a virtual machine you
put the virtual machine the virtual
machine rounds at the end of the
execution virtual machine disappear and
in principle you are safe day and I put
data there and the Conte content of the
data is legal in France I'm okay and I
do not have to care if the company
Center data or store data some languages
assume you know since I meant to
pornography by the way Steelers in
probably the most part for business on
the internet assume that maybe make the
opposite made that you know storing
pornography data in France a is is legal
but say it's not legal in Germany now
the data then get transferred to data
center in Germany where Zeus data are
illegal again you are protected by the
SLA so in principle you should be
protected in Europe but you know and I'm
not illegal espresso don't quote me ok
this is at the best of my knowledge ok I
was not here ok so now what is important
for some everything with said is
generically goes for business go for
everything but what is important for
science I mean you know everybody now
has you know smartphones now smartphones
are becoming a fantastic scientific
instrument because you know you can take
pictures you can push data to the to the
cloud I mean there is standard
interfaces or easy you know think about
medical application can be an area where
there is no medical support no medical
expertise you know you can have you know
easy sensor you know you've seen gadgety
everything else you're going to some see
the major you know you are your physical
data by your data and through a food you
can upload it on on the cloud and there
you can get medical expertise so so that
is you know same phonus mind so you can
capture data in a very simple way put
everything on the car on the cloud you
have a fantastic power or
the computer you need to have and there
you can then expose to the researcher
today to the user you know it in a very
simple way and use you know you know the
familiar tools everybody use you know
you can use Excel you can lose
everything so you can really do science
in a very very simple way thanks to the
power of the cloud and the power of
virtualization so you know simple tools
to answer complex question so you can
have sensor in the ocean collecting
environmental data or put on the cloud
and there you can access with a
spreadsheet and you know anyone without
being a computer scientist but just a
domain scientist can work on those you
can have you can have genomic data
genomic data again being inserted you
know in a spreadsheet and there you can
you can work on genetic in a distributed
way in a very simple way so so is the
power of the of the clouds virtualized
resourc combined with the easy of access
of conventional tools which make you
know Clouseau relevant for science so
there is this line where we try to
capture the OL idea of these you know
tremendous transformation that a cloud
support so today you know we have a
pyramids where you know we have very
experienced high performance computing
user you know you know we're discussing
the beginning of my talk you know their
discern you know the particulate the
practical physics is you know when i
started in particle physics my first job
was to take computer throw everything
away and redesign everything the binary
loader the operating system the library
is the runtime libraries the compilers
because we wanted a very you know
real-time rental system we couldn't buy
one we build one so you know physicist
know how to do I performance computing
so are you know many other disciplines
and this is really the top of the
pyramid the people who use
supercomputers supercluster etc then you
have everybody you know in the middle
that you know then
or to use pretty powerful compartmental
class and so forth big servers and then
you have everybody else you know there's
mole team of few biologists you know in
an indie studio somewhere without really
access to computer expertise so that is
today so what is it is not a dream what
is happening now very much thanks to the
virtualization the cloud a move towards
a unified research community where you
have powerful simple to use tools the
data the data and analysis tools are up
in the clown so you don't need to
maintain you do need to to apply patches
or anything like that somebody does that
for you so you can be communities you
know you can use a kind of social
computing approach to to science and you
can marshal they need resource on demand
you need more because you have a
conference well okay let's through
10,000 core to your program and then you
know once the company is over you can
release it so that was very effective
and and all that is going to accelerate
discovery so we move from a fragmented
pyramids to and unify the global
environment so what will that means this
domain in the few minutes that are left
I'm going to tell you what you know how
we try to prototype that you know 22
years ago what I'm telling you now and
now think is uncontroversial you know we
we get down to a little implementation
details you know is the data secure how
to control the data what are the legal
issue everybody seems to me agree that
you know cloud computing is where
scientific computing is going we like it
or not that's where technology drive in
us so 23 years ago we we are ready at
this idea we said well maybe we can
prototype that and maybe we can
prototype that in an account not just in
Microsoft but you know Microsoft can
join a bunch of European partners in the
contest of in European you know project
that we call the newseum in you know
there is a Greek important component in
the consortium they proposed window see
and you know you invent acronym and then
you do reverse engineer for the awkward
to do something that is relevant so I
don't even know what it stands for but
basically the idea was okay new crews
you know she is the vice president or
European Commission and she's also the
european commission commissioner in
charge of the Digital Agenda so she's
very in charge to transform the European
economy in a digital economy by 2020 so
that's why she is responsible for the
next frame or program which is starting
is going to start in 2014 and his collar
eyes on 20 24 Reza Reza so between now
and 2030 years ago in 2020 we had this
challenge given to us by Nick rose and
here near close appears at our Microsoft
cloud interpretive center in Brussels
which opened in march two thousand
eleven so basically it told us at that
speech you know where three pillars for
cloud in Europe the legal framework and
you know the question you asked really
showed that that is important pillar the
technical and commercial fundamental
elements can commercial providers or
computing technology provide us the
right infrastructure to implement the
Digital Agenda and then you know the
development of the cloud market by
supporting pilot project cloud
deployment so we said okay let's have a
part of project so what we did is this
venue see so we put together a back
ignore ah we put together a bunch of
partners and you see you know people
that providing cloud infrastructure
which was essentially Microsoft we
deserve k th who are in in Stockholm and
they have big clusters and the Barcelona
supercomputer center workers have large
supercomputers so we wanted to see how
cloud could fit in an overall scenario
where you have clusters supercomputers
and clouds commercial cloud Azure so we
we had you know a bunch of other
activity to disseminate
no the the result of the project to you
know cooperate and also the issues to
the training and then do the scenario so
that's where it's very much the essence
of the project take infrastructure
providers cluster supercomputer and
clouds put them together build on top of
that a development environment which was
developed by our colleague actually by
the guy who just called me now you know
the our colleagues in Aachen Germany
were part of the Microsoft atl esau
advanced technology lab Europe and and
really build a number of user community
around that and and see if our theory
that that are the best approach to
modern computing is is correct so you
can see we started with seven use a
scenario that go from structure nozzle
building with University of Valencia
building formation management for green
buildings in in train to Italy that is
there is a unit of the foul you know the
UN agency that is responsible for food
and agricultural civil protection
emergency in greece by informatics are
again upon the technical Valencia
computational system biology our joint
institute in trento in drug discovery
University of Newcastle so that way if
you like a relatively a significant
seven different area where we deploy in
our application and we are the pretty
good success story so now you know I'm
reaching to the end are not going to
spend much time but I mean you know
already mentioned or the collaboratory
oh and you start top is a very
interesting way by which by providing
cloud computing you can actually enable
startup to really develop very valid
business model and opinion are basically
doing a workflow for green building the
the most probably impressive
demonstration of the power of the cloud
was the system to help the fire
protection and fair prediction in
island of Lesbos in in Greece because
they're against the typical you know is
there is the killer application you know
you need to have a tremendous amount
computing power during the summer when
the risk of fire is very high but during
the winter you don't need the
infrastructure because there is hardly
any power so having a kind of elastic
virtual infrastructure is perfect for
that so those were our big success story
if you go to Venus c dash c dot you you
can you know you have a very nice
website you can get a lot of information
and again I'll be I'll be happy to
entertain question for the rest of the
week and then with the spirits of the
first year with a very successful review
last year amid need the midlife we're on
we solicit a new application and we got
a bunch of new application so by now we
have 27 and I think you know we
demonstrated to need close to the
European Union you know that our
approach was a correct one is very
effective and somehow is the
demonstration all what we've been
discussing in this last hour so just to
uh to draw a conclusion that is the last
light we believe that the valid add the
valid the value added for science of
this new approach you know difficult for
paradigm collie the calc and beauty is
that by distributing managing creating
data that is much better served by
virtual scalable and elastin freh
structure last in the sense you know
you're spending when you when you need
when you don't need you reduce it
because of the economy of scale that we
discuss the energy cost which has
tremendous the environmental impact it
is much reduced and so all those are
better addressed by the current cloud
computing technology virtualization
computing free structure can also
support funding agency in developing new
fund in developing new funding model so
rather than give you money to buy your
own cluster they can give your resources
on the Klau which much more effective
when your project ends they can remove
and they can get the resources somebody
else now if they give you money to buy
cluster at the end of the
argenta cluster is lost so that is what
I capture and say moving from capex so
capital investment to OPEX operational
investment so these eventually will lead
to more science per taxpayer euro
dollars or pounds whatever and and
faster and that is also much faster to
deploy their conventional
high-performance computing in emerging
scientific and business community so
that's really the message I wanted to
compare to you and I'm happy now to
entertain any question you might have oh
we can discuss offline now there are
some resources i think there's lies
we're going to be made available so you
can actually go to all those website and
there is some references if you want to
read a little bit more okay done thank
you thank you for great see you thank
you very much that's very interesting
with probably of time for a couple of
quick questions and I realized standing
between between you and coffee so here
we go thank you I'd like to ask about
load balancing so basically if you look
at for example logging crafts or utility
crafts or some systems or networks you
can see sort of an oscillation between
you know when for example Western world
is awake and vice versa so how is this
management so the system is our capacity
for that period but not so high capacity
for other periods well uh donation fully
understand I mean actually the the fact
that there are different time zone and
the infrastructure goes across many
times will allow this kind of
optimization so not only is a good a
kind of automatic backup because you
have the copy of your date in different
centres but you can also actually
applies or streaks so basically you know
when let's say United States is leaping
probably there are more resources there
than in Europe so you can push your
computational date and again because you
are essentially running virtual machines
is very easy you know which are
contain you can move your you know you
can do load balancing across time zone
so I mean yes so the answer to your
question is yeah load balancer cross
timezone is done by everybody and
actually there's no new because even in
grid computing we're doing that in Greek
you know the we are discussing the large
other chrome lighter you know CERN
before you know the eggs at the
beginning of my talk well already there
in a conventional grid we were moving
the load of analyzed the LHC data from
forests in the center of the Academy
academic academia sinica in Taiwan you
know at a certain time of the day and
then move it to Europe you know
basically was you know following the Sun
cycle okay so moving from east to west
with the Sun just to profit of that you
can also built in in the cost you know
you can make the cost in the states when
it's nighttime cheaper than the cost
during day time and that somehow promote
this kind of load balancing through
times o those lemon okay well thanks
sorry we have actually run out of time
now and we're really honored to have
four bricks of state Oh am I are today
and I'm sure they'll be around sometime
for a couple of questions later on but
once again can be thanked for great seal
thank you